[Music]
hey you guys
tomes of terror time so this book
this is probably the one that it's
probably like the most recent one
in the sense that it came out really
really soon when i'm reviewing it so i'm
kind of proud of myself
you know what i mean this book just came
out in march 2021
and i'm recording this in may 2021 so
i'm like really on the ball with this
one
this is like even it's a hardback yo i
got the hardback it's not even out in
paperback yet
and this book is the lost apothecary
by sarah penner look at that cover i
love this look
i love this cover so much it's like kind
of shiny so i'm not sure if you can
actually see it
but yeah so like i said that book only
this book only came out like two months
ago
and i've been hearing like so much buzz
about it and i saw like all these
reviews and everybody was like really
excited it was
you know i saw like a bunch of
booktubers that were kind of like it was
on their list for most anticipated
during the year and the premise for it
sounded really really amazing and you
know
if you know anything about me you know
that i love [ __ ] about
poisoners like i don't know why i find
poisoning really fascinating i like true
crime about poisons i like stories about
poisoners
and since this is about a poisoner i was
like really really jazzed to read this
one
now i will say from the outset this is
not
a horror novel i'm not even sure what
genre i would call it really
it's kind of like it's historical
fiction
it's sort of a mystery thriller type
thing
some of it said in the modern day too
it's almost
kind of like i saw some people compare
it to something like the da vinci code
or something like that there's a tiny
tiny bit of like magical realism in
there like
that maybe magic could be real but it's
kind of left ambiguous
so it's not like scary or anything like
that but
it was still like a really really
enjoyable book it wasn't exactly what i
was expecting
like from the um the synopsis that i
read
but that said it was a really
it's a really easy read i almost want to
call it like a beach read
in the sense that it's pretty fast-paced
it's not real
dark it's not real uh dense
you know it says it doesn't go like real
uh in depth into a lot of the characters
and stuff
it just keeps moving along at a good
clip so if you like like historical
mystery type stuff
or you know things about poisoners
then you would probably really dig this
i did see that a lot of
the reviews on this were sort of mixed
in the sense that a lot of people
on goodreads like really really loved it
but then i saw a lot of booktubers
reviewing it and a lot of them i mean a
couple of them really really hated it
and a couple of them just thought it was
okay but it was just like disappointing
i wasn't really you know expecting a
huge amount i just said well if it's
about a poisoner and it's kind of like a
thriller mystery type thing then that's
cool that's good enough for me
so i didn't have it built up in my head
to the point that i was just kind of
like oh that wasn't what i was expecting
it was kind of what i was expecting but
not exactly but i will say don't go into
it expecting a horror novel because it's
not
and it's a pretty light read in the
sense that bad [ __ ] happens in it like
people die and everything but it's not
a bummer you know what i mean it's just
a really really easy
book to read now this is sarah penner's
debut novel so for a debut novel it's
actually quite good i think like i said
if i was going to give it a star
rating which i don't usually do and i
don't do that on a lot of my reviews i
just kind of do it haphazardly
i would maybe give it like a three and a
half it was like it was enjoyable enough
that i read it really really quickly
because i think it's only like 300 350
pages or something it's not super long
but it was just kind of like when i put
it down i always kind of want to pick it
back up again and see what was happening
so it really did keep me uh interested
in
where it was gonna go like where the
mystery was gonna go the
characters are a little underdeveloped
but
the plot keeps moving pretty quickly so
that didn't really bother me all that
much
so let me kind of give a breakdown of
what's going on in this book
so as i said it's sort of historical
fiction but some of it said in the
modern day too
so it goes back and forth one thing i
will say that it goes back
and forth between two sets of characters
well pretty much in the modern day
you have a woman named caroline that's
from that's in the first person
and then in the past uh which is in 1791
which is when the historical part is set
you have actually two characters one
woman the
apothecary uh whose name is nella and a
12 year old girl
named eliza fanning and depending on
who's doing the [ __ ] it goes back and
forth between those two characters but
all of it is in the first person
so sometimes it's a little bit like each
chapter is called
like nella or eliza or whatever so you
know who's talking but
it's in the first person so you're
jumping between three different
characters but they're all speaking from
their own point of view
so just it's a little bit confusing but
you do kind of get used to it after a
little while
so in the present day we're following
this woman caroline
now she has been uh her and her husband
were had planned this
uh this trip to london for because
they're from cincinnati or whatever
and they had planned this trip to london
for their 10th wedding anniversary
and they had all of this i think they
were going to stay a week or two or
whatever
and they had all this itinerary and she
was super super excited about it and
she's super excited about oh we're you
know then we get back we're gonna have a
baby and all this other stuff
so a few days before
they leave on the trip however she uh
accidentally discovers that her no-good
husband james has been [ __ ] around
so obviously she's not real jazzed about
going on this anniversary trip which was
supposed to be this big romantic trip
where they're going to try and like make
a baby or whatever
and she's like okay well now i don't
want to go with him
so she decides [ __ ] you i'm going to go
by myself which i was like you know what
good for her
so she goes by herself and makes his
cheating ass stay home
now one thing about caroline is that
she's happy in her life until she finds
out this
about this cheating [ __ ] but i think
like she still
kind of has a little bit of lingering
resentment i guess because
i suppose she got like a history degree
like about i guess it was like a
bachelor's
and she was actually going to go to
cambridge in the uk
and do her masters but then she got
married and then
uh her husband was kind of like an
accountant and he's all very mr
you know we can't run off and study
history he'll never get a job doing that
it's not practical yada yada so
she ended up taking a job like just
working secretarial or like a clerk at
her
parents farm um you know which was a
more stable position
but she was kind of like she seemed like
a little bummed out that she didn't
really get to use a lot of her
studies that she had done and she was
like really interested in
so she had it wasn't like a big deal i
guess but it's like she still had like
some lingering resentment about it
so when she found out that james was
cheating on her and she's sort of at
this kind of crisis
in her life and she goes to the uk by
herself
it's almost kind of like so this is
almost kind of like a
a woman you know coming into her own
and like and like finding herself again
type of story too
so there's a little bit of that aspect
so if that sounds like something that's
going to turn you off
then you might not be into it it doesn't
bother me i'm not real into that kind of
it's not chiclet i'm not going to say
that and that's kind of like a reductive
term
but i tend not to like a lot of um
these sort of stories of like you know
women finding themselves or all this
other kind of stuff it's like some of
them are good but
it's not usually a genre that i'm real
crazy about but so it does have a little
aspect of that but like i said i wasn't
really bothered so she goes to the uk by
herself
and on a lark she kind of decides when
she's just kind of wandering around sort
of bummed out about where her life's
gonna go now
she runs into this guy who's heading a
tour group who's going
mud lurking in the thames now this is a
real thing and i guess sarah penner went
to the uk and she actually did this so i
guess this is where she got the idea
so there's groups of people that go and
they'll kind of um
sort through the mud like on the banks
of the river at various places
looking for you know old artifacts that
they find
you know that they think are interesting
so she decides yeah what the hell you
know she's really into history and she
likes that kind of [ __ ] so she
joins them and does it and she ends up
finding
this little bitty blue vial
with something that looks like a little
uh bear
etched on it so she gets kind of
interested in it she's like oh i wonder
where this came from and she asked the
guy and he's just kind of like oh i
don't know it's probably from an
apothecary shop
but usually you know usually an
apothecary shop would have like the
address on it or like the logo of the
store and this one doesn't have that it
just has that bear so that's a little
weird
so she gets really intrigued so she
decides uh that she's going to
investigate like where this vial came
from
because as i said she's really into
history and she felt like she'd been
neglecting it because of you know
getting married and having to have a
boring job and all that kind of stuff
so it so happens that the guy that runs
the mudlarking group his daughter
named uh gainer works at the british
library so
caroline ends up going there and they
you know start to solve the mystery of
where this vial came from
now this whole time like while this
story is going on you're also going back
in time
to 1791 to this woman who's i guess
she's like a middle-aged woman i don't
really say i don't really think they say
like how old she is
but she runs uh an apothecary shop
now her mother owned the apothecary shop
and her mother
all she did was make medicines like you
know for for women it was it was a an
apothecary shop for us specifically for
women um you know for
she would have all kinds of tinctures
for you know
i think she did like some magical [ __ ]
too but you know mostly just stuff for
like pregnancy and you know
your menstruation and all that kind of
stuff so it was like a woman specific
type of thing
but she was a healer now nella
uh inherited the shot from her mother
and she had a very very bad experience
also with a shitty dude of her own who
not only cheated on her but also did
something really really bad which i
liked really shitty that i won't spoil
and uh
she decides no what um i know all this
stuff about
uh plants and poison stuff i'm gonna
kill that [ __ ] so she did
probably deservedly so
so from that point forward she decided
she does healing remedies and stuff too
from the apothecary shop but
she also starts selling poisons her one
caveat being
that she will only sell poisons to women
to kill men
she will not kill a woman she will not
knowingly
you know administer a poison that she
knows is gonna kill a woman
so uh so she's been doing that and
obviously because this is very illegal
even in 1791 london
she had to basically hide her apothecary
shop
so if you come in this door like there's
it looks like there's nothing in there
it's just kind of like this storeroom
with like a barrel or whatever
but her shop is like behind this false
wall
that has like shelves and [ __ ] on it but
she has such a reputation around town
that people know
like hey if you need a poison you write
down what you want
you stick it in this barrel like in this
little store room
and she'll pop out and get it and mix
the poison for you
so it's kind of following her story as
well
and she uh at some point this little
girl who's 12
eliza she comes to the shop because
she works for a woman who wants to kill
her stupid husband
and so eliza is has come there to
you know get the preparation made now
eliza gets really really interested
uh about poison and about the occult and
magic and stuff
so the two uh the two of them nella and
eliza kind of strike up this sort of
unlikely friendship sort of thing even
though nella doesn't want to involve
this little girl
in all of this chicanery that she's up
to like killing people and whatnot
but eliza is so interested and she won't
go away so it's almost kind of like but
her meeting eliza ends up
having uh pretty dire repercussions uh
along the way um so yeah so i this
this book since it just came out just a
couple months ago i don't really want to
spoil too much about it but it's
it's basically a parallel thing you are
following
you know in 1791 you're following nella
and eliza and they're poisoning
uh shenanigans and you know maybe
they're going to get caught maybe this
is going to happen maybe that's going to
happen and that's like a really good
compelling story because like i said i
love [ __ ] about uh poisoners
and then in the modern day you're
following caroline who has found this
vial
which if you didn't figure it out uh
came from that uh the lost apothecary
shop
and you're so you're following caroline
like figuring out where it came from
you know eventually like digging up the
shop and all this other kind of stuff
now as i said this is a really quick
fun it's just a fun easy easy breezy
beautiful you know what i mean it's that
kind of it's it's not deep
uh it's not all that dark even though
it's about
uh poisoning people which it's a little
strange but you know what i mean
it's you know i mean it's it's just kind
of like it's just an easy read
and so if you liked you know stuff like
the da vinci code or something like that
i saw a couple people compare it to that
which i guess is sort of
it's a similar kind of thing like
historical mystery now
i will say that it's a book that
you really like i said the characters
aren't super deep
caroline in particular does some kind of
stupid [ __ ]
you know what i mean or stuff that's or
unbelievable [ __ ]
and her husband james also does
something kind of unbelievable
like toward the end because like a
douche like he shows up because she's
like
hey i came to london to get away from
you and he just shows up like the next
day like
oh i chased you over and she's like oh
goody you know what i mean so it's that
kind of thing
so there so there's that whole issue so
you do i will say that you do
have to suspend your disbelief a little
bit
because some of the stuff that happens
just seems a little too
uh seems like plot contrivance you know
i mean like
oh how convenient that this that the
other thing so there's there's some of
that
but it's just one where you kind of i'm
not saying like turn your brain off or
anything like that but i'm just saying
it's just kind of like a fun
adventure mystery type of thing if you
like
stuff about uh that era of england if
you like stuff about poisoners which i
do
then you will probably enjoy it i
thought it was a perfectly fine
enjoyable book like i said it kept me
interested all the way to the end
you know it's not a great work of
literature or anything like that but
like for a first novel
it's actually really good and it has
like a bunch of interesting [ __ ] in it
obviously sarah penner like i said she
went to the uk she
went mud larking she did a massive
amount of uh
research about poisons and about the
laws back then and how [ __ ] would have
worked and stuff so
you know i i just think it was just a
really fun enjoyable
read and so if that sounds like
something you would like like i said
it's not horror uh
it's historical fiction a little bit of
magical realism in there just kind of
sprinkled over it
a little bit of a mystery thriller
suspense type of thing
there is suspense in the form of you
know are
are nella and eliza gonna get caught for
all the poisoning you know is caroline
there's something that happens in the
modern day too with caroline and her
stupid husband
and uh you know what i mean she doesn't
kill him or anything but um it's
something along those lines so so it's
kind of like a parallel story so
it so it's that kind of thing so if that
sounds like something that would be
your cup of tea then by all means check
it out like i said it's not out on paper
but
in paperback yet because it's too new so
um i
can't remember how much i paid for the
hardback it wasn't horribly expensive
but i just honestly like it sounded cool
because i was like poisoners i'm in
and uh and the cover was so beautiful
yes i'm that shallow like well i mean
like books are concerned i'm just kind
of like a nice cover really does
help your [ __ ] out a lot so that's why
you should hire a professional graphic
designer
like me but yeah so uh so i don't
remember i don't think it was horribly
horribly expensive but it's out in
hardback and you can get the audiobook
as well
um i've heard the audiobook wasn't great
but i don't really know because i'm
i don't i can't really get into
listening to audiobooks it's just like
it
my mind starts to wander like when i'm
listening to other people talking
so i can't really concentrate on what's
up i have to have it in front of me like
i have to read it and like have it going
on in my head
i can't just listen to somebody else
telling it to me so i know that's weird
but i know some people like to listen to
them but
i i don't know so i don't know if the
audiobook is any good or not i've heard
it wasn't good but
that was just from a couple people so
take i take that with a grain of salt
i'm just saying
but you know it's it's just a fun book
like i said probably like three and a
half stars
you know there there is some stuff in
there that i was just kind of like what
that wouldn't happen like that or why is
she doing that like you know what i mean
you know there's just
but it was mostly just little [ __ ] i
wasn't really like all that concerned
about it
and overall i thought it was just like a
really fun read you know so that's all i
can kind of say about it
so check it out if that sounds like
something you wouldn't enjoy
and i will see you guys on the next one
bye